[Music]
thank you for tuning in to the dean show
and my next guest coming out
was someone who was scratching the
records
and making a dance and giggle and
just having a great time he had three
records out there and he was
living without a purpose he was chasing
the money chasing the wine chasing the
honeys
but now he's found purpose and we're
going to benefit from his story
because many of you are out there living
without purpose but you know something's
missing because money
can't fill that void that woman or man
that house that big mansion can't fill
that void
and you can't buy a six-pack a piece
piece is something
that comes from the owner piece so we're
gonna be talking about
this with our next guest the famous
fabulous
they call them the dj the scratch i will
get his uh dj name when he comes back
we'll be right back with our special
guest former dj here on the dean show
[Music]
this is
[Music]
this is
now now tell us let me grab your hand
now they they
the deep did i say it right they used to
scratch
like you scratch your head but they but
did i say it right because i've been a
little old you know what i mean
so i'm not hip on these things but when
you used to scratch the records
some people might think that you're
tearing it up that creates that sound
right that the people used to like yes
yes so used to make the people dance or
get them to dance used to be the life of
the party
and you know i mean that was you know i
was just
involved yeah i had a you know myself
and a good friend of mine
um who's muslim now too yeah um
but it was through music that we found
islam too which is interesting
and um no no we did a show with you was
um
talking about your story how you came to
islam and we talked about some of these
things and that was back in the sd days
right standard we're hd now thank god so
let's briefly talk about bring people up
to speed used to be a former dj
and and and we talk about these things
because we really want to show people
that we can connect with them we've been
there
done that and some people are doing it
right now what many of us
left and still sometimes doing it right
in and out i mean i think it's a
struggle that we go through
uh islam is about struggle keeping that
purpose is a struggle
um it's a jihad it's a jihad man it's a
jihad
and yeah i mean i was involved in that
um
djing and then i went to college i had a
degree in education
um and became muslim my freshman year in
college
um and then when i became muslim i was
lucky to have
a west african teacher from synagogue
who actually i studied with for 10 years
i lived with him and studied with him
for 10 years in oklahoma so i memorized
the quran with him
because i felt like as a convert um to
islam like the purpose of life to
handbook is the quran
when i was a christian i wanted to
memorize you know proverbs
in the old testament because i felt like
that's all the wisdom
when i became muslim you know my teacher
was like
you know start with the quran so um in
like two and a half years you know i
memorized the quran in arabic with him
and then continued to study um and i
didn't even want to become an imam like
i didn't have that intention i was just
a convert
who wanted to learn and practice what i
learned
my degree was in education i love to
teach kids
and then got hired as an imam and then
studied in egypt for seven years and
just kind of came back but how do you go
from turning scratching the records
and you're i mean obviously this is
happening in nightclubs and you got the
women like hey dj play that song and
you're making money
and you're living a dream you know what
i mean so how do you go from this before
i was 18 years old i mean i had three
albums out
when i was in high school yeah three
right three you had three records out
yeah and and um so you're getting paid
you're making money
you know you got your celebrity status
in in the nightclub i mean
i wasn't making enough money but i was
there was some local
little local fame yeah that was
definitely a precursor to
you know i had been offered and i you
know a chance to move to new york and
work with warner brothers
at that time and really launch and uh my
father because my father is dear to me
um as a professor
and he was like no get an education yeah
um
and really came out of a mid
middle class background but went to an
inner city high school to play
basketball
so i had kind of like this duality in my
life
and and then came came out of it
not really satisfied internally so
even though all that was happening and
potentially happening
you know i played for some anr people
and so on and so forth to get a record
contract but
i just wasn't happy and and and i
realized that my happiness was beyond
this world
there was something else that i wanted
out of life
besides fame you know i've been there
while i made six figures
you know when i was very young and the
only thing i got out of it was a big tax
bill
and and it was weird the more money that
i made um
like the poor i became it's hard to
explain the more responsibilities that
money brought me
i'm not encouraging anyone not to make
money i think money is very important
right as the prophet mentioned the hand
that's on the top is better than the
hand at the bottom yeah
but i was just a lesson that i learned
from myself
and realizing that ultimately defining
who i was for me was going to be
god-centered
and not club-centered not girl-centered
not drug-centered
uh not money-centered yeah and that's
what caused me to make that move
but how about now i mean as soon as you
and most people i mean i know people
that have been
you know in in in the car with their
friends late at night
and they're telling looking at each
other you know and they're
picking out what burrito place to go to
the nightclub's over and they look at
each other and like you know what we got
to change
but many of them they don't move towards
change but now as soon as you bring up
you know religion it's not the cool
thing you start talking about these more
important questions it's like
you get kind of uh labeled black labeled
you know so
how how did you go through this now
you're you wanna you uh get more
serious in your life more spiritual and
now your friends they
they start looking at you different so
how can we change that perception i
think i think it was also a very
different era
like the early 90s um when i was
involved in these kind of
kind of i guess hipster culture type
things or whatever
yeah the early 90s was still very
spiritual in many ways
a lot of the hip-hop artists were of
course not
perfect but no one's perfect but there
was a very strong
social message like public enemy there
was a strong spiritual message
people like tribe called quest rakim
even like outside of hip-hop right um
so there was people that i was djing for
who were muslim
people that i used to smoke weed with
unfortunately were muslim
like the conversation in the car i had
that with my best friend who was muslim
we were like high as a kite listen to dr
dre so what i'm talking about right now
that was
that happened to us on yeah he's dead
now i forgive him but
that was really the first conversation i
had and not encourage anyone to go smoke
marijuana
in the car but that that was just what
allah gave me so you're relating to the
story that's what people are that was me
that was happened all the time yeah but
i wasn't talking about you no
yeah and you didn't know that yeah right
um that wasn't a setup
so it was through those human
interactions you know with daryl in
particular
that i was like don't you hate white
people don't you believe muhammad is a
god
why do you treat women like crap why do
you kill people
i mean this is the guy that i smoke weed
with and listen to music john coltrane
miles davis
um nirvana right but he's still
a vehicle eliza used him as a router for
me to get near allah
so that was a very profound experience i
was 16 17 years old having conversations
about who allah is
in a car smoking weed with a guy at two
o'clock in the morning
and so and he was a muslim yeah yeah you
know
we all have our struggles man y'all
forgive him i mean but allah used him to
guide me every good i do now he gets it
yeah because he's the person who led me
to islam and you're living purpose now
yeah are you happy with him yeah of
course can you when you compare we
almost got to go to break but now
what is it is it like day and night
compared to back then yeah i mean
there were good things that happened
then as well i don't think you still the
baby out with the bathwater but
definitely i mean just having purpose
um and feeling that you're here for
something greater
is just invaluable it is isn't it yeah
we'll be right back with more with our
special guests here
on the dean show the apple of macintosh
dazzled the world it was invented by
steve jobs
but who invented the apple repeat
ah
[Music]
please subscribe to the show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
back here on the dean show let me ask
you another common question that people
when you bring up religion people say
look i don't want to follow any
organized religion
okay so have you heard this were you one
of those also that
you know you just okay i'm a man of
science religions are man-made i don't
want to follow them
religions are the cause of all wars and
now the door is closed
well rationalism and newtonian science
has taken us to really dark woods
you know where what has science given
the soul
so science can tell us
what should make us happy but it can't
answer why people aren't happy
you know except out of like a psychosis
to see people have mental health issues
why wasn't michael jackson happy
guy had an elephant in his backyard man
a freaking elephant in his backyard
he had like a pet monkey bubbles
you know and i'm not making fun of him
i'm just saying like he had everything
everything yeah but he had nothing at
the same time spiritually he was still
and he seemed to be a very i mean man in
the mirror is a very spiritual driven
song
yes right so and that's not
and you see muslims who are rich
beyond their wildest dreams and they're
the happy and you see poor people who
aren't happy too but the point is
that that means that it's not that
science can't answer that question
right spirituality is is the domain of
of allah the hearts
knows what's in our hearts so i would
say
if you reject organized religion then
you're adopting your own disorganized
religion
right because what what other language
do you have it's then it becomes very
self-centered you know i i have my own
belief
i i feel the one what's the difference
between you and someone who feels like
doing something explicitly evil it's
both rooted in selfishness
and that's the beauty of islam because
islam starts from the point of i have to
admit that i need
to submit i need to humble myself
the the best fruit grows on the lowest
part of the tree
right but we're in a society now where
we're told our rationale
right our sense of keenness and
intelligence right which is important
right
is ultimately the the decider on what
makes us happy
and that's not true because if we were
all given what we wanted this world
would be
hell on earth i'd take everything you
had right now
and you'd probably take everything i had
i'm just saying if that was the case
we'd be carnivorous beasts
yes then secondly and secondly
the absence of of admitting that i don't
know things so how could i follow myself
to the truth when i know i lie
you understand what i'm trying to say
here like i know that i'm not perfect so
then how could i
lead myself to a perfect being perfect
god so that's just that's just logical
fallacy it's rooted in really
it's a cop-out it's a cop-out and then
because people don't be responsible
and then secondly it's it's and god
knows there might be people are
truthful in that too but i'm just saying
i see it as a cop out and i see secondly
it's very selfish
let's talk about con i mean common sense
because that's really all you need to
to come to the conclusion this way of
life that we live if anyone takes an
academic scientific
rational approach usually the common
sense that the creator is giving us
they'll see that this way of life
islam is truly from the creator and
before we get into it more
let's talk about the common sense of
just purpose things you know nothing
that we see around us
usually is purposeless it's with a
purpose but what about us as human
beings the keys in our pockets have a
purpose what about us
yeah is there anything out there that
doesn't have purpose
and if if you buy something and it loses
its purpose what happens to it
garbage right um and that's why the
hadith of the prophet islam the
prophetic tradition excuse me um where
the prophet would say
you know teachings to us when he said
that you know when god's name is no
longer mentioned
the hereafter starts when the thicker of
allah is no longer made
then the the end of times will begin
because we've lost
our purpose our purpose is to worship
god
so when he's no longer mentioned that
means humanity has lost his purpose
and when you lose your purpose or when
something loses a purpose we do what
with it
we cast it out right so as muslims we
believe that our purpose
the illah the reason that we're here is
to worship allah
subhanahu wa not because god needs us to
worship him
no because he blessed us to exist
right and if people the people doubt the
value of existence
there's that justin timberlake movie
where you have to pay to live
it's a really interesting movie where
you actually like have to pay to keep
your life
like you know how we have like calling
like phone cards where you pay to talk
yeah
it's like there'll be a time we have to
pay to breathe like you have to pay to
live right
we actually pay to talk to people now
right we call people right so that in
itself tells you the value of life
imagine if i had to like there's a
calling card for every single word i
ever said
there's an eddie murphy movie a thousand
words or something right so
that shows you that we have value
there's a purpose a great purpose for
humanity
right and when we're not given a purpose
we like to party man yeah you know in
1957 there was an article in life
magazine called the
problem of leisure that american culture
is going to lose its deep protestant
roots which are rooted in
building the society you know the wpa
creating a culture now it's man let's
just kick it man
it's just chill right so
that's a problem and we share that with
other religions other religions also
have this idea of
you know you're here for a reason yeah
it's not just chaos
now you also went from being a former dj
with the records and
and that to uh you know you knew you
knew the bible quite well you were
christian
so someone says who's out there you know
our brothers and humanity
and we want the best for everybody uh
they say look i am worshiping god i'm
worshiping jesus
the one who we love is one of the
mightiest messages of god um so what if
someone says this
to you uh yes i wasn't a bible scholar i
was just a kid went to church man and
you know memorized
scripture and all that stuff exposed my
grandfather was a preacher
um but i would say to them that you know
our response would be
um it's great that you have a faith
right we're in the age now where faith
is on the endangered species list
yeah um however we don't believe that
that's the true faith
as muslims respectfully doesn't mean we
can't live together yeah
unfortunately people some people don't
do a good job of that with our tradition
and other traditions right
but jesus died dude jesus slept
he ate he used the restroom so he
exhibited
qualities of creation not the creator
right so we believe that whatever should
be worshipped the object of worship
which is
the one who fulfills the qualities of
being the one who's worshiped number one
is that he has no beginning
he has no end right he has no
no needs jesus had needs he cried and he
wept who did he pray to in the bible
himself
he prayed to someone right
that the creator is one in his essence
in his
attributes and his actions because he
doesn't need anyone else
like those are the qualities that we
should look for in a creator man
so it's impossible for us to believe
that we should worship something that
has the qualities of creation
it's just not possible we're going to
ask you a little bit more about this
when we come back
these qualities that the creator should
have and that's the creator that we
should worship it should make sense
to be logical be right back with more
here on the show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]
back here on adinsha we're talking about
the qualities of the crater you
mentioned that jesus
according to the christians he died so
that means if you're you're saying that
jesus is god that
he's um he's even resurrection would be
take you out of being god yeah he ate he
slept he prayed
you mentioned something when we met
years back that if uh
the creator became a man that he would
have a nationality speak a language he
would uh can you uh
yeah definitely i mean once you turn the
creator into creation then there becomes
this race war
um and that opens up another problem and
then how could that creator be the
creator of
all if he exhibits and that's why for
example jesus wasn't white
but when you go to most churches in the
west jesus
looks like you know he looks like
richard marx yeah
it looks like i don't think anyone knows
who richard marx is he looks like
you know he looks like ben stiller the
pictures that they portray yeah because
they want to portray
god as them right that's the sick subtle
yeah
kind of freudian slip there you go to
like you know the
vato locos or like yeah like the the
barrio and i'm not saying that to dis
disrespect anyone's culture
jesus becomes like you know ricky martin
yeah you go you know to the
african-american community jesus looks
like usher
so i'm just saying like everyone is
portraying christ
as themselves although it's described
that he was a man of dark
olive skin he had nappy hair you know
that clan member could never
have really had the image of christ as
described in the bible in his church
because he was persecuting and killing
that image
right that's that dichotomy so we
believe that
god number one they're basically he
exists
right because if he didn't exist we
wouldn't exist
number two he has no beginning he has no
ending
right number three he's one we say one
we mean one in his
he's not one of 800 or one of three he's
one
right in his attributes he's one he
doesn't share
and his no one is like god's mercy um
when people say you know
you know how could a killer be forgiven
by god exactly because his mercy is
transcendent it's not like our mercy
third are the things that he does
creation
right the next is that enough that allah
has no needs
al-samad samadhi the one who
provides and doesn't need anything from
anybody and provides without
being forced to right or obliged to
that's why we say even the guidance that
you and i have every muslim out there
who's muslim
you're muslim because god blessed you to
be muslim not because he had to make you
muslim
it's that's why hidayah means gift
hadiya in arabic
it's a gift that's put in the heart it's
the same word
right and then we say that
after being free of all needs and wants
is the absolute
rich who can provide us for whatever we
need so there's like other things and
the opposites will be impossible he
doesn't exist he has a beginning
he has an ending and most important that
he's like his creation we say he's not
like his creation
creation is not like him and that's why
we would say you're worshiping an
entity that has the qualities of
creation
and they'll say well it was only
momentarily well momentarily made him
like creation
momentarily is a created thing god is
not momentary god
was is and will be as it said in the
bible the alpha and
the omega that means in every way so
when we say that god momentarily became
a man
just the word momentarily makes him
creation and we have a problem with that
how about son of god you hear this a lot
say no no we believe that he was the son
of god
i have a theory about that i'm not a
scholar of the hebrew language but you
know there's other places in the bible
where people called sons of
god and my understanding is that son of
god is what's called ildafa to tashreef
in semantic languages meaning that
that you would say that to someone as
like we say the masjid is the bait of
allah
the house of god is the masjid really
the house of god
why do we say it to show honor to show
its closeness right
so son of god was used like david said
you are sons of god in the psalms
right be o children sons of god jesus is
quoted as saying that peace be upon them
in the bible
so the idea is that you're not literally
the son of god but figuratively
you're so close to him it's like you're
part of a family
and that's one of the arguments i would
say but definitely it's not ever been
understood
except later on after christians you
know 150 years or so 100 years
after christ the idea of christ being
god and people him being the literal son
of god
came into play and that was of course
adopted later on um
you know by the the leadership of that
empire and then they forced that there
were a million christian creeds until
that time
right so i i would say i i have a theory
on it that son of god is
yeah that it's an honorable possessive
like
we say you are the servant of god am i
really just like my servant of god no
it's to show honor i i've heard also
that this um
possibly uh when you go back to this uh
the semitic languages that
it was mistranslated actually meant
slave of god and they must stop him i
haven't looked at research that would be
interesting
uh so how about someone before we come
to an end now someone says look but
i believe this is what i've been taught
that he died for my sins
and where do i go now you're telling me
that uh you know something totally
opposite when i was raised my whole life
you go to allah right we believe allah
the forgiving and you go to the creator
of jesus and ask him to forgive you go
to the god that jesus prayed to in the
mount of olives
they said he prayed until he sweat blood
into figurative usage
right and and that's the challenge of
translation people forget that there's a
figurative usage
they say pray till he sweat blood i
doubt it was literal
right but who is he praying to himself
so i would say go to god
the creator of all and ask for his
forgiveness
because if god needs someone to barter
with you for your forgiveness
then that means he's like us again the
quality of him not being like us and
we're not like him is violated
because now he needs an intermediary to
forgive you
right and that that's problematic before
we go now can they start give them
something that they can start with can
they start
right now uh no matter what they've done
in the past to reach out to call upon
look uh you know the as a former
christian the lord's prayer
i think this is really similar to what
we have in the quran it's
you don't see anywhere in here telling
you to call it on the middle man
it's all about praise to the creator
right
i would say the first chapter of the
quran is the ultimate prayer yeah
um i would encourage people to keep
following your show
i have a website um.com that's a lot of
articles written by converts who've
become scholars yeah
um twitter and facebook i'm there you're
there
yeah but i really think starting with
the quran that's what i did i found a
copy of the quran i hid it in the
restroom i didn't know it was supposed
to be in the restroom
i was scared of my parents yeah and i
just read the quran for three years
yeah that's all i did and i just read it
and i was like this is the truth man
that's it yeah and start in themselves
did i have to give god a name to say my
creator the one who created me guide me
yeah of course i could start saying god
knows god god's not petty
yeah all these languages were created by
god
beautiful thank you very much we started
with peace we end with peace thank you
peace be with you
peace be upon you and thank you for
tuning in to the dean show so take this
small advice but yes
priceless start asking the one who
created you to guide you
and really start to put time aside to
really reflect about the purpose of life
and ask the owner of life to guide you
continue to tune into the dean show
reflect
reflect upon the destroyer of all
pleasures death you know so many people
have
died while we're filming this show you
know young people that old people died
take a trip to the cemetery you see
and they leave everything behind so all
the money
all of the cars all of the things that
you deem important at the end you leave
it behind
and then if you lived only for this life
and then you die what did you do to
prepare for the next life
think about that really think about it
and
don't forget to follow us on the twitter
like us on the facebook keep up with all
of our shows
and until next time peace be with you
please subscribe to the d
show follow us on our official facebook
and twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below